Curious about glutathione? Should most breast cancer patients include this with their supplement regimen?
I would say no. So the pros and cons of glutathione. So glutathione is your main, your primary,
intracellular inside the cell antioxidant. So
you have processes of oxidation and antioxidation going on in your body, extra cellally,
immediately outside the cell and intracellally inside the cell. So the glutathione is your
made intracellular antioxidant. It's made in the cell and it breaks down oxidizing agents that enter
into the cell. Now, whenever you listen and read about oxidizing agents, you think of them as
poisons or bad guys, things that oxidize cells can cause cancer. So that's true. So any
poison or a toxin is an oxidizing agent and it's cancer causing it can damage cell membranes,
it can damage the nucleus of the cell and if it damages the nucleus of the cell, it can be a cause
for cancer by oxidizing the amino acids in the DNA. It can damage the DNA. So oxidizing agents
can be damaging. However, there's a balance to that. Everything in physiology has a balance. Your
body actually makes reactive oxygen species for the purpose of killing biotoxins. So when you have a
biotoxin, let's say you have a bacteria or a virus, your body will make reactive oxygen species to
kill that virus or kill that bacteria. So it's all about balance. So remember that. So I know we live
in a world where you read a lot about antioxidants and you should be taking a lot of antioxidants.
Well, there may be truth to that. Taking a lot of antioxidants can be helpful because we're
exposed to so many oxidizing agents and pesticides, chemicals, heavy metals, toxins,
microtoxins, all these things are oxidizing agents. So trying to balance out the amount of oxidizing
agents that are damaging their cell or have a potential of causing cancer with taking some extra
antioxidants can be helpful. However, if you're trying to kill cancer, you have to keep that balance
using too many oxidizing agents because sometimes your body uses reactive oxygen species to kill
cancer cells. That's exactly how chemotherapy works. Chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent and
cancer cells to be tend to be more prone to damage to oxidizing agents that a healthy cell does.
Be partly because a healthy cell is healthy because the components of the cell are doing their job
and glutathione is a component that's recycled within the cell. So you don't actually need any
exogenous glutathione. A healthy person not exposed to excess oxidizing agents does not need to take
glutathione as a supplement. Why? Because glutathione is recycled inside the cell. It's oxidized
and reduced through a process of recycling inside the cell. So yeah, it does need the nutrients in
order to do that. So taking some nutrients that can help that, but typically an average person
would get their diet as well. So why would a person take glutathione? It's all because they're
realizing that they're exposed to a lot of oxidizing agents. So they want to support the glutathione
pathway. Why wouldn't a person take glutathione? If you're doing chemotherapy, if you're doing another
oxidizing agent, like there's different supplements that kill cancer through the process of oxidization,
protocell is one of those things. So you don't take glutathione when you're taking protocell.
And you've got to keep that balance. I only tell cancer patients to take glutathione if it tests on
the cheek swab that it's okay for them to take it. If you're reading my book, I'm not so positive on
glutathione with cancer because you are, you know, cancer. Cancer cells are more prone to die through
oxidation. And if you are, you could actually be keeping cancer cells alive by taking glutathione.
So I only tell people, I only recommend glutathione with people that it tests well with. Otherwise,
I don't suggest glutathione. And I don't suggest excess antioxidants with cancer patients unless
it tests well. So lots of times in the natural world, if you go to a natural path or a car
practice or some natural doctor who's who's reading literature about, you know, other health conditions.
And then you have been a patient there. I said, now you get, you know, you're going to diagnose
the cancer and that person is helping you, but they don't really have a specialty in cancer. They
may put you on high dose antioxidants. And that might not be the right thing to do. So there's some
things that you would normally that could be helpful for you from a nutritional standpoint. If you don't
have cancer, and those same things might not be the right thing to take if a person does have cancer.
So it was a very long 10 minute answer to the question, should most breast cancer patients include
this with their supplement regimen? The answer is no. And the reason is is that you may be keeping
cancer cells alive by taking glutathione, or you may be counteracted in oxidative therapy that
you're doing either chemotherapy or some nutritional in oxidative therapy. So the answer to this
short answer is just no.